what degree or skill do you need to do
that and what
if you were putting a job description
out for a 3d printer model or what would
the job description say the title
it could be a mechanical engineer um oh
so that's sophisticated yeah
that would be the most typical thing but
there's so many types of people using
you know there's
there's again dentists who are who are
literally dentists are learning how to
do yeah
drawings yeah there's kind of
specialized dental cad that literally
lets them move teeth around and do
things like that there's dental cad yeah
what's it called
uh one company is called three shape
that makes it yeah
does that go on top of some other
software or is like is there some
industry standard 3d software that
people
no there's different cad for every
type of market so it's like mechanical
cad dental cad
movie and entertainment industry cad
you're kidding i had no idea
we take models from all those different
software for different applications what
is the standard for a model like what's
the pdf or the jpeg
it's called an stl stl yeah and you just
feed it in stl and it makes it yeah yeah
we we take stl from all the software and
then we have to have a lot of
intelligence on our side of software to
be able to deal with
each one of those types of software kind
of doesn't great you know
output great stl so we have to process
that
yeah and you also have to know if the
person has made something that the
printer is capable of printing
yeah and that's actually a huge part of
our innovation is in exactly that
typically
before we got started you'd have a
mechanical engineer
type person who's trained on using a
printer who looks at what you're trying
to print
figures out how to orient it is it going
to print it this way or that way
add support structures that hold up the
part and sort of designs a process for
that printer to print that part
right had to automate all of that if we
want because making the printers cheaper
doesn't necessarily make them more
accessible if they're just as difficult
to use
right that was part of what that
hobbyist movement sort of missed is
the printers got cheaper but they were
still really difficult to use right so
we've also made them more accessible and
that
um it hasn't made them a consumer
product yet but it's gotten them to way
more professionals and way more
industries here's a stupid question
i've also been pitched on businesses or
seen them at like demo days
where they say we make the machine the
cameras that will take this cup
do a bunch of cameras in a circle around
i don't know what they call that
and that grandma tree grammar tree
photogrammetry
photogrammetry yeah it's when you take a
lot of photos and reconstruct a 3d model
from got it
do you make that device as well who
makes that device how much does that
device cost
there's um there's software you can
literally use on your phone
to do photogrammetry it's you know you
get mixed results but
you just literally walk around an object
yeah you put it on a pedestal and you
walk around it yeah
wow yeah uh so yeah there's there's like
this ecosystem
of cad software 3d scanning technology
and so
you know different companies are working
at different parts of that and we have
to kind of work with all those companies
so we're getting to the point where
somebody would be able to
put a part for you know this is the
other one i would get it's like you're
on a desert island or you're on mars
and something breaks so instead of
bringing you know to your mars colony
10 different backups of every single
part you just bring one 3d printer
and then you put the part into the 3d
printer if you haven't already made a
model of it
it just takes a picture of it and makes
it how far away from that
uh nasa has actually launched a 3d
printer to the international space
station already
and they've done some experiments with
that they printed some some parts out
so it's um it's getting there yeah the
the bigger
part that's honestly missing from making
something like that happen is you want
to design those parts for 3d printing
it's hard to take something you made
with a different process
and then just translate to 3d printing
and get the same result
but if you designed your you know mars
colony
with everything designed to be 3d
printed then that that's pretty much a
reality today
oh wow so are people have is there an
application on planet earth
that does that where you're like you
know what it's hard to get here it's the
north pole
you know and now we're going to build
our base station in
antarctica or the arctic and say
everything's 3d printed send a 3d
printer a bunch of spools
or whatever resins you what do you call
the resins you do yeah we call them
resin yeah resin okay wow it's a
technical term for resin
uh but it's not in a spool it's in the
liquid it's kind of in this black
cartridge really yeah show it i want to
see it i didn't know they were in the
goo so this is sort of like prometheus
right the goo from aliens
uh yeah i mean that's what you make in
ohio looks um
it does look like the goo from
prometheus it does look like the goo
from prometheus i'll show you uh and
just as a total aside
max how great is prometheus as a science
fiction film
it's so underrated correct it is it is
great it is underrated i love you you've
seen it
i'm gonna set the over on direct 3.5
you've seen it more than three times or
four times how many times you've seen
prometheus
at least twice uh yeah maybe three yeah
it's so good it's like gladiator or
goodfellas when you're changing channels
and you hit on prometheus
you're gonna watch it to the end
fastbender as an android he's already
kind of
fast bender is amazing he's already an
android and so he like it works
perfectly
no i mean he he's the android of actors
i'm sure he would appreciate that yeah
unlike christian balance no oh here we
go look at this printer so here's the
pinpoint
look at that lattice work there that
looks like the
eiffel tower or something yeah you can
make really fine structures with this
process
so this is what's inside the machine
there's this laser we call it the lpu
light processing unit that
scans the laser back and forth and then
it comes into the bottom
of a liquid tank of resin
and the part actually emerges
right from that resin yeah t-1000 style
yeah t-1000 right like terminator uh
and what do your 3d printers start at
now what's the range of cost
uh starts at about 3500. cheap
yeah what are they what and that's for
an industrial one that's more like that
that's our flagship product that's you
know bought by professionals in all
these industries
no it used to be that the spools were
really expensive if you wanted to build
like a hands
let's just call it like a grapefruit
size object
how much plastic resin i know it depends
on the density but just ballpark
is it one to ten dollars to print
something in plastic or is it 50 bucks
to print something
um in you know this size part might be
ten dollars a resin
we charge 150 dollars per liter so
depends how you know big your part is
right and how dense it is right
yeah uh typically you're not making like
solid you know you don't make a sphere a
solid sphere